you know I mean about prayer in general
you said information and uh figuring out
how to get stronger healthier smarter
all those kinds of things
a part of me
believes that deeply you know you can
gain a lot of knowledge and wisdom
through learning
but a part of me believes that all the
wisdom I need was all was there when I
was 11 and 12 years old
and then it got cluttered over well
listen I can't wait for you and Conti to
talk again because
when he gets going about the
subconscious and the amount of this that
sits below the surface like an iceberg
and
and I and the fact that when we're kids
we're not
obscuring a lot of that subconscious as
as much and and sometimes that can look
a little more primitive I mean I mean
the kid that's disappointed will let you
know a kid that's excited will let you
know and you feel that raw exuberance or
that raw dismal and I think that
um as we grow older we learn to cover
that stuff up we we wear masks and we
have to to be functional right I don't
think we all want to go around just
being completely
um raw but as you said as you get older
you also you get to this point where
you're gonna go
you know what what are we really trying
to protect anyway I mean I have this
theory that you know certainly my
experience has taught me that a lot of
people
but
I'll talk about men because that's what
I know best
whether or not they show up strong or
not
that they're really afraid of
being weak like they're just afraid like
sometimes the strength is even a way to
try and not be weak right which is
different than being strong for its own
sake I'm not just talking about physical
strength I'm talking about intellectual
strength I'm talking about money I'm
talking about
um
expressing Drive I've been watching this
um series a little bit of uh chimp
Empire oh yeah so chimp Empire is
amazing right they have the head champ
he's not the head chimp but the the
alpha in the group yeah and he's getting
older and so what does he do every once
in a while he goes on these Vigor
displays he goes and he grabs Branch he
starts breaking him he starts thrashing
him and he's incredibly strong and
they're all kind of like watching I mean
yeah I immediately think of people like
they're dead lifting on Instagram and I
just think displays a Vigor this is just
the primate sewing that displays the
Vigor now what's interesting is that
he's doing that specifically to say hey
I still have what it takes to lead this
troop okay then they're the the ones
that are subordinate to him but not so
not so far behind it seems to be that
there's a very clear like numerical
ranking there is like it's it's clear
who's the number two number three yeah I
mean who gets to mate first who gets to
eat first this exists in other animal
society too but Bob sapolski would be a
great person to talk about this with
because he knows obviously tremendous
amount about it and I I know just the
top Contour but
um yeah so number two three and four
males are
aware that he's doing these Vigor
displays but they're also aware because
in primary Evolution they got some extra
forebrain too not as much as us but they
got some and they're aware that the
Vigor displays are displays that because
they've done them as well in a different
context might not just be displays of
vigor but might also be an insurance
policy against people seeing weakness
okay so now they start using that
prefrontal cortex to do some interesting
things so in in primate world if a male
is friendly with another man wants to
affiliate with him and say hey I'm
backing you they'll go over and they'll
they'll pick off the little
um parasites and eat them and so the
grooming is extremely important in fact
if they want to ostracize or kill one of
the members of their
um troop they will just leave it alone
no one will groom it and then there's
actually a really disturbing sequence in
that show of then the parasites start to
eat away on their skin they get
infections they have issues no one will
mate with them no one they have other
issues as well and can potentially die
so the interesting thing is is number
two and three start to line up a
strategy to groom this guy but
they are actually thinking about
overtaking the entire troop setting in a
new Alpha but
the current Alpha did that to get where
he is so he knows that they're doing
this grooming thing but they're not
might not be sincere about the grooming
so what does he do he takes the whole
troop on a raid to another troop and
sees who will fight for him and who
won't this is advanced
Contracting of behavior
for a species that normally we don't
think of as as sophisticated as us